Hey,
what's going on is bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I just checking.
I'm just checking in on you seeing how you weeks go and that's all I'm doing
here.
Just running my fucking freckled Yap for another 30 minutes in my God damn life.
And you know what?
You're going to sit there and listen to it unless you don't want to.
Then you can always hit stop.
You can find another website.
You know,
watch some porn at work.
Pretend you're working,
puts you right or left hand and your slacks,
your action slacks,
you know,
rub one out.
Tell people later you got to lay off the glazed donuts.
Oh,
come on bill that that early in Jesus Christ.
You go with the just joke that fucking early in June this,
this does not show a lot of promise.
That was an under a minute.
The first just joke.
You know what I mean?
That's like when you watch one,
you know,
quickest knockouts,
and you're looking at the other guy like why the fuck did you even show up?
You know,
I could've done that.
I could've gone in there with no fucking training whatsoever.
What's so and I could have got my fucking ass knocked out in less than a minute,
you know,
although I wouldn't have the balls to then go try to figure out what I did wrong
and then come back to potentially have it again.
And that's what separates the audience member from the professional fighter that
gets knocked out in a minute.
You know,
whenever you see that there's always that guy do it.
Really.
You could've gotten top physical condition,
your tub of Shit.
You fucking sit in there.
Who eats fried dough at a boxing match?
I didn't even know they sell it.
They studied.
No,
they sold that shit at a boxing match.
You Fat.
Fuck.
What'd you think?
What'd you find that?
Huh?
He's like some fucking food whale.
You know like when,
when the,
um,
degenerate gamblers show up and they get flown in and they get this giant sweet,
they're like go fucking valleys.
You know,
they roll out the red carpet.
Fuckhead you already paid for it.
They're looking for you to buy another jet.
You know,
they probably do that with people who are really fat.
You know what I mean?
When they show up,
hey,
just to let you know,
fet frank showing up and now he's going to the box and match.
So let's bring in some extra shifts and add to the menu.
Who gives a fuck if no one else eats fried dough,
this guy will eat enough fried dough to justify it.
You know?
No.
All right,
whatever.
You got to just joke,
I'm making fun of fat people.
This,
this isn't good.
Oh,
this is what you're probably thinking,
gees,
bill,
your energy's a little bit high for Thursday afternoon.
Or maybe you're not thinking that.
Maybe I'm saying you think in that and I'm getting in your fucking head,
right?
That we advertise is filled that they do.
If they show one every five seconds rather than,
than just getting annoyed on Internet,
the Internet,
you're going to be like,
Oh,
you know what?
I think I will fucking book.
I never watch them.
Which is really hypocritical because I have,
I have advertising on this podcast,
but you also have the option to just
fast forwarding it,
you know,
just still a pain in the ass.
What I like about youtube,
it's like,
you must watch this.
So what I always do is I hit fucking mute and then I just scroll down to sooner.
I read some of the comments and I just,
just at the top of the screen,
I could see that things slide across and then I know it's fucking,
oh,
you know why he's about 20 years ago I was in a bar and this woman was an
advertising that I met and she kept telling me that it works.
Go,
it doesn't work.
Sometimes it annoys me and it makes it,
she goes,
no,
but it's in there.
It works.
It totally works.
She just kept saying,
no,
it works.
It's just like,
and I was so young and dumb.
It's like,
Bill,
this is the industry she's in.
Okay.
Why don't you just go tell somebody that their religion is wrong?
You know?
Of course she's going to defend it.
What she gonna do.
Say,
yeah,
it doesn't work.
And then she's going to go to work in the morning.
But I was younger,
you know,
full head of fucking orange,
red hair,
doing my best.
Talking to the ladies down on Newbury Street,
right?
What do you say?
They're fucking all black dress.
They're fucking golf looking chick.
That's all I remember from back then.
All those fucking golf.
Look at chicks.
Just fucking walking around down on Newbury street did doc Martins and all that
shit.
You go over to daisy Buchanan's.
That was the meat market,
right?
That was the chicks that went to the gym.
Unlike the golf wants that were on Newbury street.
There were all fucking sad,
you know,
taking the weight of the world on their shoulders,
those whores and daisy Buchanan's.
They didn't give a fuck.
They still don't give a fuck.
You know what?
It makes me fucking star fish tattooed above the butt crack.
Just walking around.
They didn't give a fuck.
Um,
guide.
Walk in there with my fucking waste link leather jacket,
my driving gloves.
Little did they know I stepped out of an 83 Ford fucking rage.
Two wheel drive,
the extra log bed vinyl seats.
Five speed had a radio,
but somebody smashed the window and took it.
Oh yeah ladies,
that's what you're fucking,
your dreamboat has arrived.
Yeah.
Seinfeld,
like white sneakers,
you know the high tops coming in,
you know,
dad jeans that were considered cool back then.
Maybe a sweatshirt that says spirit or whatever the fuck his spirit.
I Dunno.
It's a bad fucking image.
Um,
but it's a true one.
I'll tell you what isn't a bad image.
Did you guys watch?
Uh,
well I guess it is a fear of Dallas Stars Fan.
Did you guys watch game seven seven seven seven seven
the St Louis Blues.
Oh,
me,
me and say Louie.
Louie.
See You at the western conference finals.
Don't tell me the blues are choking.
This is a different year.
Fucking Saint Louis Blues.
I'm going to repeat this.
The St Louis Blues had a game seven in somebody else's building and not only did
they win,
they gave him the old right there,
right there.
Five to one.
They were up five to nothing.
At one point they were leading the series three to two and they got that
fucking,
they've got their lunch served to them,
they've got their hats handed,
whatever you want to say in game six.
All right?
Couldn't close them out.
And then they were going down to Dallas and I don't give a fuck how big of of a
Saint Louis Blues Fan you are,
you know God damn well you've been slapped in your,
in your,
your fucking sports fan face too many times by the St Louis Blues as Dick.
Okay.
They do it to every fucking year.
If they get you excited,
you go,
oh my God,
here we go.
The playoffs right in the face and then it's fucking over.
You know it,
right?
So you probably thinking that they were going to fucking blow it against the
black cocks and holy shit,
they came back and they did it right.
So now they get another game,
seven against the Dallas Stars.
And as much as you will say,
and you're a fan and you believe and you got your little trinkets and you
sitting in your lucky chair in the back of your head,
you know,
you go and these are the blues,
they're gonna fucking blow this.
And Jesus Christ.
Did they give you guys an easy ride?
Huh?
Three to nothing after one,
then four to nothing.
And I know God damn well when you're rooting for a perennial fucking loser,
right?
That always breaks your heart.
You need five goals.
Do you need five goals to feel comfortable?
You know,
I remember all of this shit back before we started winning every champion that
champion ship that exists.
Um,
yeah,
fucking red sox.
I was comfortable with like a 1213 run lead,
but not if we were playing the Yankees and it was only the eighth inning prior
to 2004.
I was not comfortable with it.
So,
um,
what a fucking,
they just,
they just went down and they just fucking,
just everything they throw at the net fucking went in.
Even what terrorists Sankoh's that weird.
His goal ever.
He's trying to pass it.
He's almost parallel with the net and it did like the magic bullet JFK thing and
somehow went into the fucking back of the net and they took that away and I was
like,
Oh God.
And then fucking stars are flying up and down the aisles.
They're stars at night,
a big and Bright
Dallas right there.
Fuck,
sorry if flying all over the fucking ice.
And I'm like,
watch this.
Here come the stars.
They're going to get the fucking equalizer,
right?
And then it's going to change the whole fucking shape of the game.
And then the fucking blues scale that gave him the old right there,
Fred,
two more fucking times,
if I remember correctly.
And then all of a sudden was fucking three to nothing and then four to nothing,
then five to nothing.
And then the fucking stars scored a goal and I said,
Oh shit,
don't,
they don't even tell me.
But then I just started doing the math going like,
all right,
this 10 minutes left,
they need four goals.
They'd have to score one every two and a half fucking minutes.
And then like two and a half minutes went by and then it's like I'm not doing
the math.
This is for,
this game is fucking over.
And um,
yeah,
I said the game was over when it was five to nothing.
But even though I said that I wouldn't have left.
Like most of the fucking douchebags fans there were along the boards.
Did you see how many fucking fans left?
They're not even fans.
Those are all the hookup culture that just went out to some VIP place
afterwards.
They really made,
they always make the,
the,
the fans of the team look bad because I know the upper deck was still packed and
when the stars last five to one everybody was left,
was standing on their feet applauding them.
I'm just letting stars Fan.
I'm not judging your fan base by those fucking,
the hookup con,
the ones who know the people at the radio station,
the fucking whores that are then going to go to a steak house and try to bank
some 90 year old guy and fucking get his ATM pin number.
I'm not judging you guys buy them.
You know when the game's over,
they should pan up to the upper deck and see all the fucking die hards.
But I'm sad to see the stars go.
Obviously they got some net mind a problems and Sagan didn't play the whole
fucking,
he didn't play the whole play offs.
And I'll tell you right now,
that's why the Bruins,
that's why the Bruins got rid of them.
Got To make myself feel better.
That's why we got rid of him.
We know we,
oh yeah.
He'll get you 30 40 goals during the regular season.
Where is he in the playoffs?
Huh?
What happened to him?
Did he sprain one of his abs dancing with his shirt off and some fucking one of
those coyote ugly bars.
It's what the fuck he was doing when he was playing with us.
I don't even know.
That's true.
That's what the rumor was.
All right,
here we go.
Okay,
well let me see here.
Eh,
Tyler Sagan injury.
What happened to him?
Well then a bag and then we're going to say he's got a lower body and the waist
area injury,
injured stars.
Tyler sagans makes progress,
but not enough.
A lower body in Juvi.
They always say that it's always a lower body body injury.
That means you're fucked up your shoulder.
You know,
cause if they say what it is in these fucking animals will actually,
uh,
actually go after it.
So yeah,
Tyler Sagan was a fucking no show day right now.
Mark Messy Aa.
He would have gotten his ass out on the ice.
Oh yeah.
You know.
Dot.
Tye was saying,
you know,
he's just a little fucking underwear model.
I'm fucking with you.
Well,
my kid,
I've been one time I fucking blocked a wrist shot and pickup hockey and I was
limping for like fucking 10 days.
Right.
That's the level of pussy I am.
So I'm just fucking around with Dallas Star fans here.
Uh,
but congratulations to the blues tonight.
Um,
predators,
San Jose sharks
game seven.
And I don't know who I want to win.
I like,
I love the predators cause I dunno,
I just liked the fucking Unis and a squish them,
whatever.
Get the into fucking hockey.
And there's something about this,
just something funny about the sharks choking every year.
And I don't know why,
but I just do not respect San Jose as a sports town.
I just can't do it,
you know,
I don't respect it.
Cause nutty.
You have the balls to live downtown.
You all live outside.
You know,
when you safe little high little houses,
I know high,
they're all made out of ticky tack and we're afraid to go downtown.
All my God is that a trolley?
You have a fucking trolley going through the center of town.
How much more quaint than they have to make it.
I'm just fucking with you.
Downtown San Jose's no joke.
Um,
in fact,
I remember,
uh,
the comedy club died.
Somebody got shot and killed.
It was fucking hilarious.
And then the Comedians,
like,
I forget who the fuck it was that week,
but they took the picture and they had like the whole Improv,
like marquee out front with the name of million.
But the comedian,
you know,
probably had some wacky photo there and then they just have a body with like,
God damn blanket over it.
Um,
so I understand that.
but then I was thinking what would be cool is if the sharks and the blues play
each other,
then somebody will finally,
uh,
sort of break their curse to get to the finals.
Um,
I don't know what the sharks I've ever made a final.
Okay.
And I dunno if the blues,
I don't know.
I can't remember the last time the blues did.
The last one I remember was they was against the fucking Boston Bruins and I
wasn't even a really old enough to even have watched that.
They might've done it sometime in the 90s and,
or,
or in the two thousands.
But I was doing so much standup.
I missed a lot of hockey back then.
So let's look this up saying Lois blows last finals.
Yeah.
I don't think they've been in it in forever.
Last finals appearances.
All right.
Saint Louis Blues Financial Problems in playoff streak.
1970 1987.
Let's see.
List of blue seasons.
I don't need this shit is too much here.
Stanley Cup champions.
That's a big goose egg conference champion.
I think that's a goose egg too.
No,
it isn't because they've been to the finals
conference champion Stanley Cup champion.
They won't have it.
Come on.
You know what?
Somebody just texted me this cause I,
I don't want to fucking,
this is year by fucking year.
Somebody actually looks at this shit watching.
Aren't you looking at,
Oh this isn't what the fuck I wanted to look at.
Season was shortened due to strike in 94 95 to [inaudible].
That's a,
you know,
I thought I answered to ask the question pretty fucking clearly.
You know Saint Louis Blues Blues History.
Do I have to hit pause,
disowned self?
That is smack a bitch.
Remember that from fucking
Stanley Cup record.
Here
we go.
Saint Louis Blues Stanley Cup.
But you know what,
go fuck yourself.
Fucky winter net every once in a while.
And I thought you had all the answers or at least somebody's making an attempt
to give me one.
It's not how it works.
So whatever.
I think,
um,
I think I almost want the sharks the win tonight because uh,
okay.
I Dunno.
Just stand out.
I do with the fucking crazy beard.
You know,
I can be fun to watch.
Oh,
back and forth.
They're blues predators.
He know.
I don't know if that's almost like a subway series of a southern cities.
St Louis is a southern city.
They tried to act like they're fucking from the Midwest.
Yeah.
Go there and talk to some people.
Jesus Christ.
Everybody there's got overall it's fucking unbelievable,
you know,
and they got a Budweiser right in that little fucking pocket.
Um,
I'm kidding.
They don't.
All right.
Um,
oh by the way,
tomorrow bump
bump,
bump up all,
Ooh.
Like Jim has done tomorrow.
My Gym has done tomorrow and Oh,
freckles is going to turn into Joe fucking wait,
no,
I'm going to get my fucking ass in shape here cause I am in writers from shape
right now and I'm dealing with science,
um,
which is almost gone.
Um,
I've been taking my antiinflammatory drugs and doing all these fucking stretches
at an even have to go to a chiropractor.
Um,
but maybe I'll go,
I don't need it keeps telling me to go,
so maybe I'll go.
But anyways,
I got my fucking,
um,
I got my fucking atomic holds,
you know,
I got my,
uh,
Mike Peg Board.
I got a speed bag for Nia.
MMM.
And then I got a,
I got a bench,
I got a fucking squat rack,
I got a pull up bar,
I get a dip thing.
And then I also got my climbing rope.
So there we go.
And all I gotta do is take my dog for a walk around the block from my cardio.
Nothing fucking crazy that beaten up the knees of the feet,
you know,
eat a salad every day,
like some fucking yoga instructor,
right.
Lay off the booze.
That ain't happening.
Lay off the cigars.
That might happen.
I have a,
I'm smoking two in June and then I think I'm done until October.
And if I do that,
then I'll only have smoked 10 for the year.
And uh,
I even think that's too many.
I just think it's too many.
I'd like to be,
I'd like to smoke six a year.
This is what I'm going to do next year.
All right.
It's going to be,
I'm smoking New Year's Day at the Rose Bowl.
I'm going to smoke at the super bowl.
Then I'm not smoking until my birthday in June.
And then I'm going to smoke once a year.
I go to a big college football game.
I'm going to smoke then and then that's it.
I smoked for a year.
I fucking enjoy the shit out of it,
but I don't blow out my jaw,
my tongue on my throat or any of that stuff.
I don't need that.
I don't need that my fucking life.
So,
um,
speaking of which,
you should probably ask yourself at this point.
So bill,
what is the big college football game you're going to this year?
Tell you right now,
Florida gators taken on the Lsu Tigers within brand new head coach.
You will it fucking Walco whoever the fuck he is.
I don't know who he is.
Um,
I'm beyond excited to go down there to the swamp.
I actually really like love both those,
um,
programs.
I mean,
I liked the Florida gators way back.
I just always thought that orange helmet with the blue shirt was just fucking,
was the shit.
Um,
somewhere along the line moving out to Los Angeles,
college football coming on so early and I had the time to watch it instead of
driving a gigs on Saturday,
I,
uh,
got into Lsu with the mad hatter is coach and,
um,
I dunno,
that's going to be a tough one.
I don't know who to root for in that,
what I want to go Lsu,
but I don't want to be that cut that goes to somebody's stadium and fucking
roots against the home team and meaning that it's not like I'm that fucking
emotionally invested,
um,
to be a Douche bag,
you know,
I'm just going to go there and just hope it's a good game anyways,
so,
um,
I don't know where I'm going to be performing,
but somewhere in that area,
that area and um,
really fucking looking forward to that.
So,
um,
I don't know.
So two more cigars in June and then I'm going to be done for awhile allegedly.
Ah,
yeah.
Right.
Bill?
Like you're going to go to fucking Europe.
Yeah,
I'm going to just have any Cuban cigar you want.
You're not going to go when it's smoke one,
but from over there for 10 days and I just smoke one.
That's okay.
Right?
Um,
all right,
let's uh,
let's read a little bit of advertising here.
All right.
Oh,
it's our old friends.
He had clubbed Yabby convenience club.
Debbie,
do you have any oil?
I won't and I won't get.
Oh,
come on man.
Delivers wine straight to your door.
Personalized.
We send you wine that is personalized to your palate slash tastes through our
pallet quiz,
our recommendations become an even more person.
Become even more personalized with every bottle you rate.
We work with top wine makers and growers from around the world world,
world,
world directly to make all of our wine.
Um,
high quality and value are $13 bottle would normally retail for 20 bucks.
That probably doesn't sound like a lot of big difference until you do the
percentage,
you know what I mean?
I mean,
five times 20 is $100.
Five times 13 is this 65,
um,
no risk.
You choose the type and quality of bottles with no membership fee or
cancellation fee and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
A creative,
we partner with local artists to develop wine labels that are unique works of
art right
now@clubdebbieistodanbroughtitonhimselfisofferinglistenerstwentydollarsoffyourfirstorderwhenyougotoclumpdebbieat.com
slash [inaudible] and it gets even,
yeah,
I know you all hate paying for shipping.
So Club Debbie at daddy loves me more than Jim will have actually pay for your
shipping on orders of four bottles or more.
So take something off your to do list.
Just go to club.com/burr to get $20 off your first order right now.
That's clubbed Debbie Dotcom.
Slash.
Burn.
All right,
zip.
Okay.
Are you hiring?
Are you,
are you um,
I just went,
what's his face in breakfast club?
Do you know why I'm here?
Are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Will do ya Johnny Odoia posting your job in one place isn't enough to find
quality candidates.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your jobs on all the top job sites.
And now you can,
um,
with zip recruiter.com you can post your jobs to a hundred plus job sites,
including social media networks like Facebook and Twitter,
all with only one single click.
Find candidates in any city for any industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch all of your qualified candidates roll in right to
Daddy.
Come to Daddy,
baby into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface,
no juggling emails or calls to your office,
no pain in the ass.
Quickly screen candidates.
Rate them and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has been used by over 800,000 businesses.
And right now listeners can try ZipRecruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com/burr.
That's ziprecruiter.com/burr one more time.
Try It for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/bar.
Hey,
if you're looking for a job,
I bet there's a way to upload your resume to Zip.
Yeah.
All right.
[inaudible] um,
tracker,
whether the hell's the top of this copy right smack,
Kaz SMAD phones,
technology has made everything wicked smapp but losing stuff's still makes
people feel really stupid.
Tracker.
It makes losing things a thing of the past.
What Gi Bill,
how the fuck does it work?
Well,
I'll tell Ya.
Trackers at coin size device,
does that locates misplaced keys,
wallets,
bags,
computers,
anything in seconds.
Uh,
just put track or on a scare crow and you're like,
oh,
this where I put it.
Wait,
they don't move.
Just put tracker onto your smartphone,
attach it to anything and find his precise location with the tap of a button.
It's that easy.
Lose your phone,
press the button on tracker and your phone rings even when it's on silent with
over 1.5 million devices tracker has the largest crowd gps network in the world.
World world,
world.
So you,
your last item shows up on a map.
Even if it's miles away,
never lose anything again with tracker listeners to this show,
get a special discount of 30% off your entire order.
Go to the tracker.com and enter Promo Code [inaudible].
The hardest thing you'll ever have to do is find their website I snort.
Go to tracker.com right now and enter the Promo Code [inaudible] for 30% off
your entire order.
Again,
that's tracker.com Promo Code Burr.
You can't tell me some stockers not going to throw that in the book bag or some
fucking Dude,
you know,
fucking try and bust them doing some shit and I don't know,
score big everybody you're paying too much for,
you're paying too much for tickets between the markups and last minute
convenience charges,
even printed home fees.
Are you kidding me?
Or what?
Use end up you and use you end up paying court side prices for nosebleed seats.
Scorebig is here to change that.
Did you know that 40% of all live event tickets go on sold and did you know that
there's a place to get these seats at huge savings?
It's called ScoreBig.
Scorebig works directly with your favorite teams and artists to get their unsold
seats at unpublished prices only was ScoreBig.
Can you name a ticket price and be guaranteed to pay below box office up to 60%
off.
Here's what you do.
One,
go to score big.com or download the new score big APP for your iPhone and find
the event and seats you want to make an offer of with score Biggs name and
ticket price feature.
Three,
get an instant answer and save up to 60% on your tickets for take your dick out
and say,
I've gone in a gag.
No,
it's not.
Never any fees and shipping is always free.
You can count on unbeatable prices and great seats and when you're in grade
seat,
she actually enjoy the game or show all the more.
Next time you go see any game or show,
go to score big first and see how much you can save for the easiest way to save
on tickets.
Download the new score big APP for your iPhone and to Promo Code Burr at the
checkout and you'll save an extra $20 off your first ticket purchase.
No iPhone,
no problem.
Get $20 off online to@scorebig.com,
that score,
big.com,
Promo Code Bar Score,
[inaudible] dot com Promo Code Burp.
All right,
let's talk attempted suicides here,
shall we?
Um,
yesterday a man in a,
a green Celtics sweatshirt climbed up the KT,
La,
um,
TV tower.
And,
um,
interestingly enough,
we're writingF is for family,
not too far away.
So we saw the helicopters but couldn't see the guy.
And um,
yeah,
so out here,
you know,
in La,
they show everything live on the news,
except now when they think somebody's going to die.
So you know,
cause a long time ago they showed this guy who was trying to kill
himself and he tried to light himself on fire and like just Suzuki Samurai and
it didn't work.
And then he got out of the fucking car,
he had a fucking 12 gauge shotgun.
He got on his knees,
put it under his fucking Chin and blew his fucking head off on TV.
And like kids were home from school.
It happened to like three 30 in the afternoon.
So like,
we can't do that shit anymore.
Right.
So what do we do?
We put on periscope and God knows there's people fucking film in the shit.
And um,
the dude's up there.
So immediately,
by the way,
he did,
he doesn't die.
I wouldn't be doing this if the guy died.
He's fucking up there,
right.
And,
um,
which I think is all a big sign saying that Kevin Durant is going to come to the
Celtics.
He's leaving Oklahoma.
All right.
And he's had enough of you wholesome,
racist people out there.
He would like to performance in front of some unwholesome racist people in
Boston.
That's what I feel.
Anyways.
So the guy's climbed up to Katie La Tower.
You're trying to get him down and got a couple of fucking air mattresses or
whatever the fuck they put down there.
And uh,
he climbs up and over the five.
And it was amazing.
The guy was up there for three fucking hours.
And I've got to tell you,
I'd be lying to you if I didn't start thinking about survivor because it really
seemed like one of their challenges where you always have to stand on like a
fucking,
I dunno like a bamboo pole with one foot,
you know,
balancing a tea cup on your head.
It kind of seemed like that after a while.
Like how the fuck could somebody stay up there that long?
And he was up there smoking cigarettes and taking phone calls and shit.
And I'm,
all I could think was
I was,
if I was going to kill myself,
I would never jump off something.
You know what I mean?
There's too much time to think about what you just did on the way down.
Right.
This just,
and it's just no way I even know it's right.
The old right there,
Fred,
it's just immediately fucking over.
It's just the,
the,
the fucking mess.
You know,
it's like,
come on man.
You know,
p so he's got a clean there.
That's,
that's the last thing you do.
Everybody said that you're dead and then you leave a giant fucking mess.
Somebody's got to come over there with the fucking wet vac and try to clean up
the goddamn scenic.
God knows,
you know when you jump off of something,
it's usually not your house.
You know what,
he really has a house big enough to jump off of them.
Die.
You usually land in the grass,
right?
So all you do is just break your fucking legs is some shit and separate your
fucking shoulder.
I'm not saying you can't jump off a house and die,
but I'm just saying,
you know,
you want to make sure you'd die,
which means you're going to go to someplace that's a little higher up,
some sort of public structure with concrete and there's people walking by,
right?
They just,
it's just such a selfish fucking way to do it,
right?
People coming up the damn straight,
you know,
hey,
I'm so excited to go see,
um,
everybody wants some,
I wasn't alive in the 80s that I'd like to see Hollywood's version of it,
right?
It just like these last two weeks have just been so wonder if funding just all
over the fucking place.
So anyway,
I just get on.
And then the worst part is if you jump and you actually fucking live,
you know what I mean?
And then you have your feet appointed in every fucking direction except the way
they're supposed to,
you know,
and then you got to go around being the inspirational speaker,
with a specially designed fucking wheelchair,
you know,
for somebody who has feet,
that point every fucking day.
I don't know,
some sort of,
I think he at that point they just have,
they wheel you in like Hannibal Lecter and then you gotta be like,
just standing there,
you know,
with your custom sneakers,
talking to some fucking group of people about,
you know,
why you have so much to lose a fucking way to find out that he got so much to
live for.
Um,
it's never the fucking answer.
You know what I mean?
Cause his bad,
think about somebody's depressed in Saint Louis is bad as their fucking life is
the Saint Louis Blues made the Western Conference fucking finals.
I mean,
yeah,
if you killed yourself,
you wouldn't have seen that.
You know?
And then you can't go down to the bar.
Everybody's in a good mood.
And all of a sudden,
some hot chick with the Saint Louis Blues tee shirt tied off at the fucking
navel,
comes over,
gives you a hug.
And I go,
wow,
that's what life's all about.
Getting a hug from a hot chick and going home and rubbing one out tour.
Ah,
I can't believe I almost jumped off that fucking distillery.
You know what I'm trying to say is don't fuck.
I can always don't kill yourself.
All right,
this has been a public service announcement.
I'm going to lie to you.
If I didn't fucking look up,
worst ways to kill yourself.
I found this fucking website.
And uh,
the unfortunate thing was the person tried to be funny rather than just
presenting them.
They tried to put their own funny spin on it like I'm about to right.
Um,
all right,
seven most unusual ways to kill yourself.
Um,
all right.
Number one,
this guy tried to kill himself by eating a bible.
The doctor said,
uh,
I was not strong enough to pull the object out of the guy's throat.
Um,
I don't believe that that's true.
I don't believe somebody ate a Bible.
I think that's one of those,
uh,
not the creationists,
the other fucking people.
What's the other people there?
I don't fucking know.
If you don't believe in creationism,
you believe in what [inaudible] Big Bang [inaudible] person.
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
the next one,
a guy killed himself in prison by stuffing toilet paper down his throat.
That's how bad prisoners,
you know what I mean?
And uh,
you know,
you ever saw a Shawshank redemption?
That seems like it seems the better way to go in a more pleasing thing to have
in an orifice.
I'm
sorry,
number five.
Skying Singapore worked at the zoo wanting to kill himself.
Natural Way to do it.
Why take a bunch of sleeping pills and go peacefully when you can walk into the
tiger cage.
I bet that's nice and quick to,
you know,
I've always wanted a pet at target too,
so I think you could get one quick Peden before he fucking grabbed you by your
throat,
gave you a nice shake.
You just go to,
it's like getting put into the sleeper.
Hold by one of the UFC guys,
except they would do it with their mouth.
Um,
number four,
this woman drank Draino and that's disgusting.
That's not a funny one because the one,
a guide to capitated himself,
he got into an Austin Martin tied a rope around his neck,
you know,
did a burnout.
Woo.
That's it.
Um,
I guess he was trying to get revenge on his wife.
I don't know how that works.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
Cause it was a lot of the cleaners today.
I don't,
you could literally bleed out in a car like that and they can,
they can get me enough if we see that pimp my ride,
they could take that Austin Martin down there in a fucking day.
They had all the materials they could take that interior,
put it back in,
and no one would ever know that you ripped your fucking head off.
Although I wonder what happened to the car.
So he just kept going.
That's another one.
Now what if someone was coming up the street doing the fucking paper route?
No one does a paper anymore.
It's an adult job.
All right.
Um,
it's one guy tried to kill himself.
He had to shoot himself three fucking times.
That's not funny.
Then another guy went out into the woods.
He handcuffed himself to a tree and then through the fucking key away,
and then they could tell that he struggled to try to free himself.
See,
that's why you never do it.
Okay.
Nobody ever fucking killed themselves except for a guy in jail.
We just like,
I mean,
I to spend the rest of my life fighting off fucking people trying to stab me a
fuck me.
I mean,
that's when you got it.
That's what God's like.
All right.
I get it.
No worries.
Die.
You don't got to explain it.
Come on in.
Come on at.
Um,
you did your time.
All right.
I can't end on suicide.
All right,
let's go with a prediction here.
All right.
Um,
tonight having watched zero predators or San Jose sharks games this year,
having watched maybe three minutes of that entire series,
I can tell you without a shadow of a doubt,
no,
I can't pay.
I have not seen it.
I know,
I'm trying to close my eyes and see the winner.
Okay.
That I believe that the winner of tonight's gay,
it's gonna be,
I'm going to say the predators.
And the reason why I'm saying the president of predators is because the St Louis
Blues were the away team and they want in our two home going to lose a game
seven on back to back nights.
Okay.
And that's the type of philosophy right there.
Why Vegas always wins because there's not an ounce of intelligence in what I
just said.
All Right,
I'm picking the predators.
That's it.
Alright.
Oh,
freckles is test to go to the uh,
asked to go to work and uh,
my gym's going to be finished tomorrow.
So starting Saturday call Billy beefcake will be to be going to a town near you
with my overdeveloped freckled Pecs,
right?
All of that type of shit.
My sciatica is going to be cured by then.
Uh,
I just don't sit down anymore.
You know,
that of course that's going to lead to some sort of feet problem.
But,
um,
anyways,
thank you for listening as always.
And,
um,
thank you for all the great emails I got on Monday.
I'm glad you guys enjoy when my wife comes on a fucking
shits on me.
You know,
I actually like it too.
It makes me laugh.
I enjoy it even though she's a pain in the ass.
Uh,
all right,
that's it.
So please enjoy the music and we'll get,
give you another half hour of a classic podcast from a,
from a year going by in a place,
I can't remember.
[inaudible]
Hey,
what's going on?
It's,
it's the Monday morning podcast that I am doing on Tuesday at 1120 in the
morning,
east coast time.
Fucking believe that.
Well,
let me slip it.
You know,
no excuse.
Actually,
I do have an excuse.
It was my girlfriend's birthday yesterday.
So,
uh,
I was being a great boyfriend,
paying attention to her and someone had to suffer.
You know what I mean?
It's like a,
someone always feels left out,
man,
or how much you try to pay attention.
My kid and I never had a threesome before.
I couldn't have one once.
I think twice.
The first time I didn't realize that it was going down.
I was so young and stupid.
I was actually sitting there and I was thinking,
why won't her roommate leave?
You know,
the fuck.
And it wasn't until like literally seven years later I went,
oh,
wait a minute.
She wasn't leaving because buck.
And then the other time,
uh,
it was right there on the table and one girl was absolutely gorgeous and the
other one,
uh,
was not gorgeous.
Let's put it that way,
was so not gorgeous that she eclipse the beauty of the other one,
you know,
so,
so they go,
hey,
you learn something about me right off the damn bet.
Okay,
well this is what we're going to do this week on the podcast.
If you guys are new to this shit,
uh,
new my page.
Um,
I didn't want to use every God damn week and,
uh,
people ask me questions and I tried to answer them.
And other than that,
I babble.
I give you information about my life and uh,
and that's it.
I'm fucking out of it or right.
I drank last night.
Okay.
I was celebrating,
actually went to this gut them restaurant in New York and went to Bible and I'm
a big fan of Mario Batali,
but I like Uber better.
Baba was just too,
it was too,
uh,
my palate was not sophisticated enough.
All right,
I'll take the blame Jesus Christ.
It was like regular dishes was shit you'd never read.
I had beef cheek,
Ravioli.
Yeah,
it was once you fucking take that in for a minute.
All right.
And they had,
you know,
they had like pheasants face fucking Lasagna.
It was always like half of what you had heard of like goose liver,
a fucking souffle.
So I dunno,
it was,
they was good.
But a Lupa is the shift.
That's the one that I liked that's got like a fucking,
you know,
regular animal's body parts that you weed mixed in with fucking a Rigatoni.
Oh,
what the fuck are you going to do?
You know,
you try shit.
she wanted to go there.
I fucking took her there.
And uh,
that's what happened
to cupcakes for breakfast.
What are you thinking about that?
It was sitting there,
left over from the party and I said,
that's a great way to start my day.
Let me get myself 9,000 calories of straight sugar.
It was unreal.
It was like I did an eight ball.
That's right.
The two cupcakes for 20 minutes.
I was just sitting there thinking,
how fucking great I wasn't.
I'm like,
I'm fucking awesome.
I could do anything I fucking the greatest.
And 20 minutes later when the sugar started wearing off,
oh my God.
I started pulling the drapes closed
laying in here like,
uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
Don't ever start your day with fucking two cupcakes.
FTE had a beef cheek.
Fucking Ravioli.
Beef cheek.
I was like,
cheek like the ass.
You being cute.
They're like,
no,
they actually,
you know what?
I didn't have the fucking balls to ask him.
I didn't want to know.
I was eating somebodies face meeting.
A Yak face.
Yeah.
Let me get the Yak taint a rag.
Rag Boon.
All right,
let's continue with the,
uh,
the continuing story of American Airlines.
If you listened to my,
uh,
my podcast last week,
these cheap ass motherfuckers at American Airlines,
uh,
you know,
the alligator arm,
the fucking food up in first class,
you know what I mean?
They had 20 people in First Class and they made five omelets and next thing you
know,
I was eating a bowl of total
over Nebraska.
Actually,
no,
that's not what happened.
Just to give you a quick synopsis,
I said,
Fuck you Annie.
A honeycomb cereal.
This is first class and I don't get a Goddamn Mama.
I don't want anything.
I said all of that with a little less anger and no curse.
So a few seconds later,
the guy came back,
all of a sudden,
magically he has an Omelet.
And I'm like,
where did you get that?
And he informed me that the pilot said he already ate so I could have his
omelet.
And I was like,
I don't want his fucking Omelet.
I want my omelet.
All right.
I don't want to starving pilot.
You know,
passing out up there,
seeing bogeys leaning forward on the Goddamn yoke,
whatever you call it.
All right.
So I sent them a letter and this is the letter that they sent back to me and I
swear to God,
you know,
back in the day if something like this ever happened and you actually wrote a
letter,
the very least they give you a free airline ticket.
And I'm,
when I say back in the day,
I mean like 2005,
2006.
Now they don't give a shit.
They just keep apologizing profusely.
This is a dumb ass letter they sent back to me.
I'm only going to read you part of it because they just keep saying the same
thing over and over again.
Okay.
I think I got the hiccups.
Like I have sugar hiccups from stuff and down to cupcakes.
Hang on a second.
It's room service.
Hello?
Yeah,
I'm going to check out about like 15 minutes.
Okay.
Thank you Jesus.
They didn't say anything.
She said hello?
I said,
yeah,
I'm gonna to check out 15 minutes.
At which point she could have said okay or older,
you know.
But no,
she just closes the door.
All right.
Okay.
Here's the fucking,
uh,
what,
what have we got here?
This is okay.
This is it.
This is the letter that American Airlines sent me.
Okay,
dear Mister [inaudible],
thank you for contacting American Airlines.
It's our privilege to respond to your message.
Okay.
First of all,
right there,
they already pissed me off.
Okay.
Don't,
don't start with off with your fucking stock line.
Like you,
Jackie Gleason,
you know,
thank you for writing as in a way we go,
a little shemen off the buffalo.
Uh,
okay.
I'm very sorry to hear of your disappointment with us and regret that you did
not receive your preferred entree when you traveled with us in the first class
cabin,
uh,
cl solace stasis.
Because we want your travel experience or in premium premium cabins to be truly
something special.
We do our best to cater our entree selections so that we can serve each customer
the entree they prefer.
This is the part which is just complete bullshit.
Okay.
They want to make sure that they serve the entree that I prefer.
You know,
you know,
you can do that.
Bringing up fucking eggs on the flight.
This is what they right to do.
So we determined which entrees are selected most often.
It's often and provision accordingly.
That's fucking bullshit.
I mean,
but then they watched Jurassic Park when Jeff Goldbloom did his little rant
about chaos theory.
You think as you take 10 flights or a hundred flights and you figure it out,
oh you know,
seven people want the Omelet
and and you know nine people once something else.
It's such bullshit.
First of all,
nobody wants to fucking cereal.
No one wants cereal at first class.
Okay,
you fucking dropped $1,500 or whatever the hell is 800 $1,500 on a ticket.
You want something of substance.
I'm sick of bitching about this.
All I know is in the end of it,
I ended up flying fucking a middle seat.
The fucking Dallas and all I got was $150 voucher to pay for one third.
They didn't give me anything.
Mr Barrow,
we are not unmindful of the inconvenience of you.
Well,
how the fuck would you be on mindful?
I wrote,
she had God damn letter.
As hard as we are trying to deliver on respecting your time by operating our
flights is scheduled.
It just wasn't possible this time.
Again,
we apologize for the disruption of your travel plans.
We're not giving you shit.
Please sly with us again soon.
We'll do our best to get you to your destination as plant.
Really,
you're going to do your best.
That's what you can give me.
American Airlines.
Well,
Gee,
you know,
we're going to try.
That's a comforting attitude to have when they're going to be flying it fucking
36,000 feet off the goddamn ground.
Oh,
do I sound like a cunt this week?
So that's basically it.
That's,
that's the,
uh,
the next level that they've taken it to where it used to be like,
okay,
we fuck you over.
And the stewardess gives you a hand job.
You know,
that was 1975.
Then in the 80s,
it was,
you know,
we'll give you a free ticket and a skinny Michael J.
Fox tie.
But those things,
you know,
when you had the little spiked out mullet and that lasted for a good 20 years
and uh,
somewhere in the last four or five years it became a,
we're going to fuck you over red back.
I'll talk to yourself.
When you think about that.
Go Fuck Yourself.
It was
299 other people on the plane that didn't fit in complaint.
What are you gonna do?
Take the train.
It's going to take him nine days to get to New York.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You know,
you're coming back.
It's just eggs,
you know of yourself.
You know what they got me over God damn barrel sounds a bit just,
what am I going to do?
Flight Ata.
You know Nina fucking,
I don't know what in a goddamn chicken from actually I think Ata recently we
went out of business,
give a flying an airline and then you know,
you're like,
Eh,
you know it was kind of weird flight and you know,
there was a crack in the inner window.
Ata.
We wanted the windows,
you know,
they got like,
they got the double pane of glass,
they got the one on the outside,
the outside of the plane,
and then they have the one,
uh,
on the inside,
the extra level one.
And that one was cracked and I believe there's a little bit of water in there.
And I said to the,
to the stewardess,
I was like a woman,
there's a fucking crack of the goddamn window over here.
I'm afraid I'm going to get sucked out once we get above 6,000 feet.
She said,
it's like going like glass,
you know.
So I didn't feel bad when they went out of business.
Now I kind of felt bad because now there's no,
there's no other option.
I guess that's my other option.
Do I sit there and I take it on American Airlines and they go,
go fuck yourself.
All right,
we're going to give you a bran muffin.
I hope you brought some water.
Or I fly another airline when their inner window was cracked and no one thinks
it's a concern.
Tanner winners crack.
Well,
that's,
that's why they got two of them.
All right,
this,
this podcast is just a cluster.
Fuck.
Let's get to some podcast questions that I didn't even,
I didn't even have the time to fucking look at this week.
Actually,
that's not true.
I went to look at them and somebody,
I don't know what's going on with my myspace page.
I don't know if anybody else has had this problem.
But,
uh,
I ended up painting will really add anybody for about a year.
You know,
every couple of days they'll get about 45 requests,
I'll accept them.
And then a day later I have 47 people taken off my page.
And it's like,
really?
We're all those people spammers.
I don't know what's going on.
So,
uh,
um,
having somebody looking at my account,
the only question I can remember,
I can't even remember what it was.
Something about fucking,
uh,
you know,
what movies do I find scary?
Um,
well,
you know what,
if you turned my flight on American Airlines into a movie,
I would've found that fucking scary.
Um,
what movies do I find scary?
Anything that involves the crazy woman.
Um,
I think the scariest movies,
one of my first got cable and the early eighties when I had a tight jeans and a
pony high tops that just met the bottom of my jeans and no one complained
because somehow you could get away with that back then.
Um,
I remember,
uh,
the first Friday the 13th,
when Jason came up out of the lake,
that scared the shit out of me.
And there was another one.
His,
here's one for you.
Okay.
I got a podcast question for you guys.
There was a movie I saw late night cable and I can't remember what the fuck it
was,
but it somehow there was somebody skating across the pond in slow motion with an
ax.
And I believe for some reason the,
uh,
the monster I'm picturing is,
is from that.
I know this isn't it,
but it,
the picture of my mind is what does that monster book where the wild things are?
You remember what those monsters look like?
In my memory,
that's what the monster look like skating across the fucking lake.
Uh,
and I know it isn't that,
but I know somebody,
what are you,
what am I,
14 listeners out there has to be a fucking horror horror film.
Uh,
whatever the flow,
what do you call someone's really into horror films.
Like Geek.
Yeah,
exactly.
A horror film.
Fucking deek.
There was that one.
And uh,
there was another one I was just thinking of and I just sat up and I can't
remember it.
I'm getting fucking age.
I literally just moved my brain a little bit.
The thought just went away.
Wait a second.
What the fuck was I just thinking?
Let me lay back down.
Let me see.
It would come back to me.
Okay.
I was talking about can we got to go back in time?
You know,
I was talking.
Okay.
The lake,
while things are,
see the side of my brain works.
It works linear.
Once I go past the moment,
I can't go back.
It's like a fucking traffic jam.
What the fuck was I trying to think of?
Ah,
Shit.
I Dunno.
Oh,
I got it.
Bam.
There we go.
Um,
dark night of the scarecrow.
I liked the old horror movies.
Okay,
this is what,
you know what I don't like about new horror movies bid.
They would that CGI shit.
They,
they can do so much insane stuff with computers that they forgot how to build
suspense.
The old ones they used,
they used to build it up.
They used to build up the moment where the monster was going to jump out at you
because they had to because it was just a guy in a rubber fucking suit,
you know what I mean?
But now that they can,
they can,
you know,
they can make it look like God still is stepping on New York.
They forgot how to build to Spence.
That's what I don't like about fucking horror movies now.
And that's a,
I think Japanese I to know everybody over in Asia seems to know how to fucking
do that.
But nobody over here it does even like,
like,
like thrillers,
whatever the fuck,
whatever goddamn thriller is like,
Take that,
that movie a perfect storm.
They had that goddamn big wave.
That's all they showed in the trailer.
So everybody goes out to run out and see it,
and then they don't develop any of the goddamn characters to the point that I
don't give a fuck about anybody in the movie.
So by the end of the movie,
I'm actually praying for the wave.
I can't wait for them to kill George Clooney and Mark Walberg and all those
other guys because I don't give a fuck about their characters because if they
haven't done anything to make me give a fuck,
they just had a couple people speak in Boston accent and you stick them on a
tugboat and I'm supposed to give a shit.
They're going to die trying to get lobster.
I'm just in a bad mood.
I'm going a bad fucking more today.
Let you know what it is,
is to God.
And don't ever start your day with two fucking cupcakes.
It seems like such a great,
I,
you know,
it's such a great idea,
like,
Ooh,
I'm eight years old.
This is what you'd want to do,
but your parents never let you,
you know?
And now I'm 39 and 51 weeks.
Finally the dream that I thought was going to happen,
you know?
Oh,
it did happen.
And then it doesn't play out.
Right.
Oh my God.
How did I forget this shit?
I know I forgot it because I have fucking two cupcakes with the sugar in my
brain.
I actually got a crazy week.
How crazy was it bill?
Um,
I flew into New York on Wednesday.
I did opie and Anthony and opening Anthony Opie and Anthony show Thursday
morning.
Then I did my show at Carolines in New York Thursday night.
I got up Friday morning,
got on a plane,
flew back to la.
I did the guys choice awards on Spike TV and then all these famous people,
they were all cool.
I had a great time.
I met Nikki Sixx.
I was way more thrilled and the after party was at the fucking playboy mansion
and I know what you're thinking.
Oh my God.
Playboy fucking mansion.
That must have been unbelievable.
Um,
I quickly realized when I got there,
there's two kinds of parties at the playboy mansion.
There's the your famous and you can come by Wednesday afternoon and actually
meet the broads that are in the magazine.
And then there's the one that I went to where it's like,
yeah,
why don't you guys all just stand on my,
in my backyard?
I literally thought I was going to show up to the mansion.
Right.
It was going to be like me and eight other people and just,
you know,
for playboy bunnies eat just rubbing on my chest.
Hey there,
big boy.
I heard you're a comedian now.
They just had,
they,
they had the,
it was definitely the beats team,
a playboy bunny.
You know,
they had the little bunny suits on and the rabbit here as well.
Let me tell you something.
And they were,
uh,
they were grade a hooter girls and he could tell there was three of them who
were clearly being paid to frolic in the pool.
And any girl with bunny ears had like nine guys around her was a fucking sausage
fest.
And this is a funny thing.
Nobody was hitting on them.
They was standing there with that fucking cameras out,
taking pictures like,
uh,
like they were at Disneyland and they ran into Donald Duck or something.
It was pathetic.
And uh,
you know,
Hugh Hefner was roped off with his three fucking girlfriends,
83 years old,
man.
Got It.
It was the shit that was the only thing I wanted to do.
I just want to go in there and shake his hand and then immediately stick my hand
in bleach to get the unbelievable smell of 50 years of pussy off of my hand and
then fly back.
But he was busy.
I understand.
He had to meet a famous fucking people.
So,
uh,
but still was still was shit.
And then I flew back the next day,
six in the fucking morning.
I landed in New York at about four 30.
I got my bag,
I went over to Caroline and I did three fucking shows,
you know,
and then I went out drinking afterwards.
And that's the kind of thing that leads you to be in a country mood on a Tuesday
morning.
You know,
I did all of that and then I ate two cupcakes.
All right,
so don't even question my fucking move.
All right.
So,
um,
so there you go.
That was my week.
Went to a party at the playboy mansion.
I did stand up on my first award show.
When is it going to be at?
You ask why.
I'll tell you it's going to be on,
on June 22nd.
Um,
and I had a great time doing the set even though,
uh,
most of the crowd was a pay crowd,
you know,
good looking people,
hot chicks texting each other and I,
God,
what kind of,
when this is going to be our bar.
And I said [inaudible],
I want to blow Jeremy Pip and it's going to be on June 22nd.
And this week coming up this week,
I'm going to be at a good night's comedy club in Raleigh,
North Carolina.
You can go to [inaudible] dot com and get all the fucking information.
And uh,
later on this month,
I'm going to be the punchline in Atlanta,
Atlanta,
the brothers call it.
And,
uh,
I think that date is June 19th or something like that.
I don't fucking know.
I can't get on this hotel internet and I have to check out in 19 fucking
minutes.
So I gotta go apologize for,
uh,
the podcasts being a day late and a,
forgive my continuous on this podcast.
I'm going to blame it on the sugar from the two cupcakes.
What a fucking half a fag,
Huh?
Starts the day with two cupcakes.
So they call me Billy to cupcakes.
Cupcake.
All right,
you guys have a good week.
Please keep the podcast questions Tom and Sarah about this week.
Man,
I had some,
I don't know what's going on with my fucking page or please keep them coming
and,
uh,
let people know about my podcast and thanks to everybody came out to my shows a
night in Philadelphia,
Chicago,
and a in New York City.
All right,
you guys all have a good week.
I'll talk to you later.
Bye.
So
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible].